HE STARTED WITH ROCKFORD BEFORE
CHICAGO
BEFORE THE BREAK.
CAN'T REALLY SAY ANY STREAKS
CARRIED THROUGH, AS IT'S BEEN
SUCHCHOT THE PUCK, CZARNIAK ACR
SABRES LINE.
PUSHED OUT FOR
BOARDS.
BARZAL CENTERS AND IT WENT
THROO IT. IN
POSITION BUT DIDN'T GET THENY O.
TRAILER.
BAILEY.O HELP OUT AND A
FOUR-ON-THREE.
DROP PASS.
TAKES A OLOFSSON.
DRAGS AND SHOOT AND LITTLE SCRE.
ISLALA
BEAUVILLIER,  MAYFIELD.AVE BEENT
THERE MORE THAN A MINUTE NOW. B.
BELLOWS PAST TUCH AND BELLOWS
SCOR EASIEST ASSIST HE'LL GET. .
AUSTIN
A GOOD CRISP PASS ALL THE AND B
BACK IN FRONTS AND LEE CAN'T GET
IT ON GOAL AND NOW HE SCORES!
TO BELLOWS AND A DIRECT PASS TO
ANDERS LEE AND OFF HIS SKATE BUT
HE STAYED WITH IT.
HE GOES TO THE HE
SUBSTITUTED IS OFF THE ICE IS
AUTOMATIC SO THEY MISSED THAT
THERE. PLAY AND
THAT BRINGS US TO A BREAK HERE.
GORING.
I'M SORT OF HMATT BARZAL STOLE .
LEAVES IT OFF FOR CHARA.A. BARZ
>> Butch: QUICK RELEASE.
REALIZED HE A AN ndan: MATT MAR
IN.
GOT A PIECE OFHAPPY.
CAL CLUTTERBUCK HOUNDING THAT
PUCK AND OPENING UP
SHOT THAT DAHLIN BLOCKED.
HITS OFF THE GLASS.
STAYSLOOKING.
THAT IS ALMOST A REPEAT OFILEY.
KREBS WITH HIM.
BAILEY SETS UP DOBSON AND THEY
SCORE! IT WAS
DOBSON.
IT HIT SOME STICK IN FRONT.
DOBSON A GOAL AND AN ASSIST,
GREENE TO IT.
MOVED TO THE HIS
VISION AND LIKE NOTHING HAPPEN.
PUCK.AME
EFFORT ON THE DEFENSIVE SIDE